can we give web 3 a couple of [ __ ]
minutes to get their [ __ ] together your
wallets and digital identity yeah how do
you tighten up a wallet where you
actually are like really proud with all
of your best stuff like where it's your
stuff yours not like somebody else oh
that's true that's 24 months everything
will be cleaned up first of all we got
coinbase coming i'm hearing rumblings
that instagram's coming openc is going
to continue to develop they just raised
13 billion is that right did i see that
right kayla yesterday what do you think
they're gonna make this awesome i was
there where winelibrary.com
server was in my closet of my store and
when the power went out my site went
down no cloud computing my shopping cart
used to break all the time no shopify
like i was there when internet one
didn't work do you remember
if the internet on a plane isn't perfect
we're like [ __ ] delta meanwhile
like if your mom picked up the phone
when you were on the internet in 1996
you got disconnected goodbye so to
answer your question can we give web3 a
couple of [ __ ] minutes to get their
[ __ ] together